[Music]
these are your targets memorize your
responsibilities to be able to identify
that shoots you let's just say you're
gonna feel what happened to that kid on
the beach it changed him you can't train
that into someone gun skills martial
arts you wanna kill her here he is he's
non-compliant
oh it's fine sir makes you think you can
make through my selection process my
guess is if you and I go hand to hand
you could probably figure out inside of
20 seconds whether or not I have what it
takes to make it through selection
process so what you think he's ready
Stan actually I mean he's not ready hey
Bobe
get back up here cover my ass what's the
mission sir eliminate the target keep
rise over it wait for my orders
pardis gone mr. Terminator authorize you
to make come too I took the initiative
to disobey a direct order no I made a
decision to pursue the target and I
completed the mission and sir he's not
what I'm here to do isn't in my job job
to do right don't you to do what was
that guy in his symbol seems like he was
a step ahead of us everything he did
there I thought I'm gonna do it four
days ago 15 kilos of plutonium went
missing
weapons-grade 48 hours
[Music]
that guy he trained for the helpers he
has the nuclear weapon
that's not this guy
[Music]